en marzo de este año empecé mi último
año en secundaria fuimos la primera
semana del colegio después secreto la 40
y no obligatoria así que desde ese
momento hasta ahora toda la cursada fue
virtual fue un cambio enorme porque todo
el mundo espera durante toda la
secundaria el último año con un montón
de expectativas y tuvimos que adaptarnos
aceptar que no nos iba a tocar vivir lo
mismo ni de la misma forma uno tiene que
ser muy consciente y estar muy
agradecido de en qué posición le tocó
vivir todo esto por suerte en mi familia
conservaron sus trabajos creo que esas
cosas que antes capaz pasaron
desapercibidas o no les dábamos el valor
que de verdad se merecen hoy hoy nos
damos cuenta cuánto las extrañamos y
cosas súper básicas como ir a una plaza
y tomar algo o juntarme en una casa o
salir a hacer cualquier cosa yo creo que
eso es una de las cosas que más extraña
poder hacer lo que te gusta con gente
que querés el primero que creo que es
muy importante decirles es que tenido
durante la cuarentena que has tenido
varias actividades al canto teatro y
grabación
estoy haciendo un ejercicio ya somos la
cara ahora a la ventana para
promocionarme de energía
en este vídeo trate de mostrar una de
las citas que adquirimos estando en
cuarentena este vídeo surgió a partir de
mis clases de teatro obviamente a días
que son más alegres aquellas que son más
tristes con menos energía con menos
ganas de hacer cosas en un día normal
podría hablar con personas que quiero
durante tres horas seguidas sin
aburrirme y hoy por hoy al estar todo el
día en mi casa o sin hacer cosas
diferentes siento que no hay tantos
temas de conversación eso no hay tanto
para contar lo primero que quiero hacer
una vez que termine esto es ver a toda
la gente que quiero que extraño un
montón quiero ir al cine hay que ir al
teatro
quiero salir tengo un montón de cosas
que quiero hacer con termine